mon père s'appelle Demba Koita né de
khatifal et de m'amadikoïta et venant du
Sénégal mon père est né en 1890 et il
est venu faire la guerre 14-18 dès le
début ce qui le faisait donc 16 ans et
demi ce que je ressens mon père a
toujours été un bon année extraordinaire
donc
il est mort tantôt aussi ce qui n'avait
que
je suis de 5 ans l'aîné de mon père si
je puis dire ce que j'en ai 69 et lui il
est mort à 74 ans
sans oublier à tomber sur tout ce qui et
même si s'exprime avec son propre fils
c'est
c'est beaucoup de subtilités c'est très
discret et mon dieu
il a fait
non pas son devoir
il a combattu
loyalement
son devoir à 16 ans et demi on ne sait
pas trop
je crois que c'était pour celui surtout
dès le départ quand il est parti une
aventure non par la suite c'était une
sérieuse aventure ça je n'en doute pas
[Musique]
la guerre on en parle peu entre père et
fils ceux qui en reviennent préfèrent
souvent le silence et l'oubli et si le
père de Jean-Pierre coïta est ainsi pris
dans la tourmente de l'histoire c'est
que pour la première fois en 1914 les
Français côtoient leurs colonisés
ici même en métropole poilus et soldats
coloniaux deviennent un temps frères
d'armes
[Musique]
c'est donc la guerre qui les réunit
surtout les fronts comme ici en
Champagne on les imagine affrontant côte
à côte la violence qui s'abat sur ces
terres paisibles certes il y avait bien
des raisons de se battre mais pouvait-on
imaginer alors l'invraisemblable
souffrance qu'elle est entraînée ses
combats
[Musique]
dès le premier jour de la bataille de la
Marne j'offre demande à ses soldats le
sacrifice suprême comme si les états
majors avaient décidé cet immense
suicide collectif qui est la guerre au
nom du sacrifice sur l'hôtel de la
victoire
[Musique]
la première bataille de la Marne se
déroule du 6 au 13 septembre de lourds
comme arrêt de Saint Gon il suffit de
quelques jours pour en finir avec toute
illusion la guerre ne sera ni courte ni
nécessairement victorieuse
en cet automne 1914 on en mesure encore
ni la durée ni la violence
[Musique]
la guerre a besoin de soldats on ira
donc les chercher en partie au cœur de
cette ancienne Afrique Occidentale
Française ou la levée d'homme est loin
d'être une pratique nouvelle
dès qu'on met sur pied et tireur
sénégalais au milieu du XIXe on commence
à beaucoup les voir représentées dans la
presse ne serait-ce que parce que ce
sont les bras armés de la conquête
coloniale donc aux côtés du blanc la
présence de tirailleurs est importante
d'abord parce qu'elle légitime l'action
du blanc elle prouve qu'il est pas tout
seul et puis en même temps elle soutient
aussi cette effort de pénétration très
curieusement physiquement sur les
gravures il y a la fois le blanc qui
s'avance avec un coupe coupe qui
défriche et puis derrière lui les
africains qui ont un fusil à la main ou
d'autres qui portent comme s'il y avait
une sorte de d'accord dans le fait de
pénétrer de plus en plus loin au cœur
des ténèbres
[Musique]
mais la geste coloniale laisse place à
d'autres formes de recrutement plus
organisées et plus intensifs
on ne recrute plus pour le défilé du 14
juillet 1913 qu'applaudit la foule
parisienne mais pour le front et les
méthodes de recrutement allant jusqu'à
la contrainte entraîne alors un certain
nombre de réactions
[Musique]
la première réaction ce sont des
manifestations de loyalisme envers la
France des engagements volontaires je
viens de le dire mais les premières
réactions négatives c'est la fuite quand
les commissions de recrutement se
présentent les jeunes gens s'enfuient ou
même les femmes se regroupent et
manifestent leur hostilité par des
pleurs par des chants de départ parce
qu'on considère qu'un homme qui part ou
un jeune homme qui part est un jeune
homme perdu et que très rapidement on
estime qu'il ne reviendra jamais
et puis en début de 1915 les choses
tournent mal dans une région de l'actuel
Mali qui s'appelait le bélé on assiste à
une première révolte la chose est
d'autant plus paradoxale que c'était un
vrai réservoir de soldats qui
traditionnellement entre guillemets le
mot traditionnel en disant anciennement
fournissait pas mal de soldats à l'armée
coloniale et puis par la suite à partir
de l'automne 1915 les choses tournent
encore plus mal et une grande révolte
une immense révolte va frapper tout
l'est du Mali actuel et
l'Ouest
l'ouest de Burkina du Burkina Faso
actuel qu'on appelait à l'époque pas
encore la Haute Volta mais qui deviendra
la Haute-Volta en 1919
des plus ardents défenseurs de la levée
d'Africains et le colonel Charles Mangin
l'homme de la campagne du Soudan
originaire de la ville de Sarrebourg en
1910 il publie un livre manifeste la
force noire Mangin il développe l'idée
selon laquelle l'apport de milliers de
soldats africains pourraient pallier au
déficit démographique de la France et
jouer un rôle décisif dans
l'affrontement qui s'annonce dès 1914
les premiers contingents arrivent
[Musique]
l'appel à l'Afrique est donc intimement
liée à la question des effectifs surtout
à partir du printemps 1915 et des
premiers échecs de la France en Artois
et en Champagne
pour Mangin et une partie du lobby
militaire la solution est bel et bien
dans les ressources humaines de l'Empire
excepté une interruption en 1917 les
recrutements sèche-lonnes pendant toute
la durée de la guerre et concerne
quelques 134 000 Africains
les premiers soldats qui arrivent sont
de deux sortes soit des jeunes conscrits
soient des soldats de métiers là il y a
une énorme différence parce que on a pu
dire par la suite qui ces soldats
étaient de la chair à canon était ou
bien des mercenaires ou bien
des des
soldats Balagnas
toutes sortes de qualificatifs ont été
attribuées ces soldats en fait il y a
deux sortes de soldats et soldats
étaient déjà habités au 20e militaire
qui avait été recruté avant la guerre et
qui venait par exemple du Maroc parce
qu'on a remplacé
les troupes qui se trouvaient au Maroc
par des troupes qui étaient nouvellement
recrutés en Afrique et ceux qui étaient
au Maroc français blanc si j'ose dire et
français soldat noir ont été envoyés en
France France mais ils étaient déjà
formé ils étaient ils avaient été comme
on dit dans le vocabulaire militaire
dressé c'est le mot qu'on emploie les
autres étaient de simples conscrits
autrement dit des pauvres paysans qu'on
avait recrutés plus ou moins de force et
qu'on en voit sur le front en France
[Musique]
dès les premiers mois de la guerre on va
mettre en avant le fait que les troupes
allemandes violent
pi se sont vraiment des barbares la
guerre elle est tellement dévastatrice
qui évidemment il faut une propagande
inouïe pour mobiliser les hommes surtout
après les premiers mois de la guerre qui
sont qui sont assez pénibles pour la
France et pour l'armée française le
grand affrontement franco-allemand de
1914 à 1945 tournent autour de
l'affrontement entre barbarie contre
civilisation en 1914 les Français ont
crié au crime contre la civilisation en
affirmant que les Allemands étaient des
barbares qu'il représentaient le camp de
la force de l'injustice et que les eux
les Français représentaient le camp du
droit de la Justice de la morale et
comme symbole de cette guerre des
civilisations comme symbole de cette
France et bien les tirailleurs
évidemment les tirailleurs sénégalais
eux symbolisent cette fraternité ce
bien-être ce bonheur cette modernité qui
a apporté la France à l'Afrique sont un
peu les bons élèves ce sont les repères
ce sont les bonnes notes de la
colonisation des tirailleurs et bien
sont eux qu'on va mettre en avant dans
la propagande pour les opposer à la
barbarie allemande
[Musique]
jusqu'en 1915 il n'y a pas vraiment
d'entraînement puis en 16 on a décidé
d'en envoyer dans le Midi dans des camps
de d'entraînement qui sont les grands
des normes camps à Fréjus Saint-Raphaël
[Musique]
donc l'entraînement a commencé seulement
la manière de se défendre à commencer
seulement en 1916 de se défendre ou de
faire l'assaut alors il y a il y a un
problème vrai mythe c'est le soldat
nettoyeur de tranchée c'est vrai que de
nombreuses photos montrent le soldat
équipé du coupe coupe et c'est vrai
qu'il y avait un entraînement avec le
coupe-coupe plutôt qu'avec la baïonnette
mais il faut savoir que pendant la
Première Guerre mondiale les combats la
baïonnette ont été relativement rares
c'est pas pareil de faire des redsous en
Afrique et de taper sur les bonhommes
que de se battre ici c'est pas la même
guerre
c'est une c'est une guerre technologique
là c'est les canons c'est les obus c'est
pas c'est pas du tout la guerre faut pas
la guerre au sabre ou mousquet c'est pas
je crois que c'est une guerre auquel
c'est troupes étaient pas préparées ça
c'est clair mais pas plus le recadrement
que on a pu observer dans des combats de
1916 au moment de Verdun que certains
jeunes soldats totalement
ignorants lancaient des grenades et puis
se précipiter pour voir ce que ça
faisait dans les trous de Grenade il se
faisait massacrer par les mitrailleuses
allemandes
[Musique]
jusqu'à 1917 on les a dispersés un peu
n'importe comment soit en compagnie soit
plutôt en bataillon et puis juste
pendant toute la guerre finalement la
doctrine s'y tentait qui a une doctrine
c'était plutôt une espèce de panachage
entre deux bataillons noirs un bataillon
en blanc ou un versement le tout
consistant des régiments qu'on appelait
des régiments de marche mais il y a
jamais eu un emploi en division noire
alors on nous dit que les troupes noires
tout de même faut pas croire qu'ils sont
si gentils que ça sont des troubles de
choc et de premier ordre sur tous les
champs de bataille elles ont été surtout
utilisées en France mais aussi sur le
front d'Orient avec les troupes qui
étaient assalloniques alors il nous dit
que les troupes noires ça c'était le
commentaire qu'on avait de l'époque ont
de précieuses qualités la fidélité au
drapeau le dévouement absolu à leur chef
et la bravoure
et alors ce qui est surtout on appuie
sur tous c'est la fidélo drapeau puisque
ce sont des enfants de la grande France
et le dévouement alors chef donc là on
est déjà passé du sauvage au bon soldat
second soldat dont il est dit en
permanence qu'il est très très facile à
amuser
qu'il est très facile à commander à
condition qu'on soit ferme et donc là on
trouve en fait la description du rapport
qu'on a à l'enfance c'est-à-dire que ce
tirailleur et bien commence à s'enfermer
dans ce stéréotype qui je crois ne
quittera plus les Africains et encore
jusqu'aujourd'hui dans cette idée d'un
grand enfant c'est-à-dire qu'il a pas
encore atteint le stade ultime de
l'homme occidental c'est un enfant un
grand enfant et que d'ailleurs la
République va constamment appeler ses
enfants ou ses fils c'est intéressant de
voir combien jusqu'à une date récente
encore on utilisait le terme enfant pour
parler de tous les les membres de
l'ancien empire colonial en 1915 sort
une affiche qui depuis est devenue je
crois la troisième
icône la plus connue dans l'histoire de
la publicité c'est il y a bon [__]
donc ce tirailleur il a souriant avec sa
caisse de [__] et qui va donc à la
fois
emblématisé la grandeur de la geste
impériale
le Gabon le bon enfant c'est à la fois
un sujet de
d'attirance c'est un appel publicitaire
en même temps que c'est un rejet
pendant toute la guerre de 14 une
production iconographique énorme énorme
j'ai pu comparer la production
échographique au sujet des maghrebins au
sujet des indochinaux au sujet des
Africains celle des Africains
représentent je dirais 60 à 70% celle
des Maghrébins
peut-être 15% et celle des indochinois
le reste donc il y a une
sur-représentation du tirailleur
sénégalais
une sur représentation qui est loin de
rendre compte des relations entre
soldats et de leur ignorance mutuelle
comme en témoigne cet extrait de l'être
écrite par un lieutenant à sa mère un
Bikou fumait la cigarette ce qui n'est
pas indiqué pour une relève de nuit
effectivement son sergent n’espérant pas
lui faire comprendre son erreur veut lui
enlever la cigarette du bec le [__]
Apple doit du sergent et le mort
jusqu'au sang le sergent gueule le
lieutenant s'amène et use de la matraque
il tape il tape sur le [__] puis il se
fatigue appelle l'adjudant et lui dit de
continuer l'adjudant amène le [__] dans
un coin étape
et le lieutenant dit à sa mère combien
je me félicite de n'avoir pas employé
les mêmes méthodes de commandement mais
je crois qu'il ne peut y en avoir
d'autres avec les [__]
[Musique]
la bataille de Verdun est encrée dans
nos mémoires une bataille qui n'a pas
d'équivalent dans la grande guerre pour
celui qui n'a pas eu l'expérience
directe de la violence guerrière une
interrogation demeure comment les hommes
ont-ils pu endurer l'enfer que fut
Verdun
ce fut un siège de plusieurs mois mené
aux abords de la Meuse un siège dans la
finalité a été l'anéantissement de toute
vie 700 000 hommes tombent dans les
champs les bois les Landes
[Musique]
par décret du 5 août 1915 j'offre qui ne
croit pas à une attaque sur Verdun fait
désarmer l'effort de la région celui de
Douaumont est pris par les Allemands le
21 février 1916 sans combat c'est ainsi
que nait ce que l'on appellera le
scandale de Douaumont
conçu pour 800 soldats le fort en abri
de plus de 3000 les conditions de vie
des hommes sont dramatiques l'eau manque
la puanteur du lieu donne la nausée les
combats sont d'une rare intensité
[Musique]
cette croix marque la sépulture de 700
allemands tombés dans le fort
les hommes qui montent vers les
premières lignes savent qu'il n'en
reviendront pas tout recule et
sanctionné la consigne de l'état-major
se faire tuer sur place
face à la puissance de feu allemandes
les Français répondent par la résistance
de leur infanterie coupée de leur
bataillon et de leurs arrières les
soldats sans terre et n'ont d'autre
choix que de se battre
il faudra attendre le 24 octobre 1916
pour que les troupes coloniales
intégrées à la cinquième division de
Mangin reprennent définitivement le fort
on relate que ce fut dans un magnifique
élan mais au prix de terribles pertes il
ne reste plus que quelques hommes dans
les bataillons de tirailleurs sénégalais
malgaches et Somalie
symbole de la résistance française face
à l'agression allemande Verdun sonne
comme une victoire
mais une victoire qui ne modifie en rien
la nature de la guerre elle ne se
terminera qu'en 1918 avec la prise de
Saint-Mihiel par les troupes
franco-américaines et cette terre de
Verdun porte encore la trace de ces
milliers d'obus tombés sur ses villages
entièrement rayés de la carte comme le
village de Fleury dont il ne reste que
ces crevasses
ou encore celui d'Orne et ses piliers
d'église
dressés dans le silence
certes les Allemands ne sont pas passés
le déroulement de la bataille de Verdun
aggrave les tensions entre les milieux
politiques et les états majors
militaires il aura fallu 200 000 hommes
pour reprendre le fort de doux au mont
et ce qui devient l'affaire de doux au
mont entraîne la destitution des uns et
la nomination des autres
Mangin reçoit les félicitations de
j'offre et les éloges d'une presse qui
célèbre en lui le sauveur de Douaumont
s'il est un exemple de l'absurdité de la
guerre c'est bien celui de la butte de
vos quoi du nom d'un petit village situé
sur un site stratégique permettant
l'accès à Verdun
après les premiers grands assos qui ont
débuté en février 1915 il ne reste plus
rien du village et de ses 160 habitants
à la suite de ces combats les
adversaires consolides leur tranchées
creusent des boyaux aménage des abris la
collines perforée de toutes parts une
véritable cité souterraine les hommes
vivent et combattent là avec l'angoisse
de l'explosion souterraine ou des gaz
qui envahissent les galeries les troupes
coloniales ne participent que très peu à
cette guerre des mines juste lors des
assauts de 1915 ensuite les hommes se
relaient quelques 2000 hommes françaises
et allemands vivent une véritable vie de
taupe avec pour seul objectif faire
sauter l'ennemi distant à peine de
quelques dizaines de mètres
[Musique]
cette lutte menée sous terre ne fait
guère avancer les positions de chacun
des adversaires le front est resté
obstinément fixé au milieu de la Butte
ce sont donc trois longues années
absurdes et meurtrières pour une
conquête qui finit par perdre tout
intérêt stratégique
l’année 1917 coûte dès les premiers
jours de l'offensive du Chemin des Dames
30 000 morts et 54 000 blessés côté
français
cette année sera particulièrement
désastreuse pour les troupes coloniales
qui ont été massivement engagés
[Musique]
le 16 avril l'attaque a lieu le centre
de l'attaque et c'est sont les troupes
de Mangin cette attaque se déroule par
un temps épouvantable la préparation
d'artillerie s'était faite pendant toute
la nuit par une préparation énorme de
milliers de canons mais les Allemands
étaient au courant ils avaient reculés
pour l'essentiel sur 50 km ils avaient
laissé dans ce qu'on appelle les crottes
c'est-à-dire la le Chemin des Dames
c'est-à-dire les les falaises et les
grottes du chevalet d'Inde des nids
mitrailleuses qui n'avaient pas été
détruits par l'artillerie
[Musique]
pour avoir lu certains journaux de
marche des bataillons je n'ai pu être
absolument épouvanté et plus ému en
pleurer par certains passages où dans le
journal de marche secrétaire raconte
après que les soldats noirs étaient
tellement paralysés par le froid et
l'effroi qu'il ne pouvait même plus
manipuler leurs armes et que c'était des
soldats blancs à côté d'eux qui les
aidaient à les manipuler
il arrive que ses combattants anonymes
retrouvent le chemin de notre mémoire à
travers les mots
quoi de plus émouvant que ceux du poète
Léopold Sédar Senghor qui s'adresse
ainsi
vous tirailleurs sénégalais mes frères
noirs à la main chaude couché sous la
glace et la mort qui pourra vous chanter
si ce n'est votre frère d'armes votre
frère de sang
ah ne dites pas que je n'aime pas la
France je ne suis pas la France je le
sais je sais que ce peuple de feu chaque
fois qu'il a libéré ses mains à écrire
la fraternité sur la première page de
ces monuments qui pourra vous chanter si
ce n'est votre frère d'armes votre frère
de sang
l'attaque reprend au mois de mai
toujours sur les ordres de Nivelles et
les choux à nouveau et c'est à ce
moment-là que le bruit court que mangea
a fait massacré ses troupes à vrai dire
la responsabilité elle est où oui
mangeant aurait dû penser quand même que
faire attaquer enfin c'est mon avis
aurait fait attaquer des hommes de
telles conditions c'était c'était les
fermes massacrés à coup sûr mais en même
temps le plan hiver était du quand on y
repense aujourd'hui d'une telle
absurdité que la vraie responsabilité
c'était quand même celui qui a conçu
l'ensemble de l'attaque l'offensive
c'est-à-dire Nivelle alors qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé nival c'est à commencer par
dire c'est pas de ma faute c'est de la
faute de manger alors
immédiatement on a accusé Mangin d'être
le bourreau des noirs et c'est venu de
la gauche de l'époque c'est-à-dire du
journal l'Humanité qui a dit le vrai
responsable celui qui a fait massacré
6000 6000 hommes c'est le général Mangin
[Musique]
en 1918 on va recruter à nouveau 60000
hommes mais sous le l'autorité en somme
d'un commissaire de la République nommé
par le chef du gouvernement qui à
l'époque était Clémenceau qui disait je
fais la guerre je fais la guerre je fais
la guerre et ce commissaire de la
République est un noir c'est le fameux
député Blaise Diagne qui est député
depuis 1914 et qui jouit d'une véritable
audience en Afrique comme en France qui
est un personnage très intéressant très
lié à certains milieux politiques
français franc-maçons notoire et qui
arrive en Afrique avec les honneurs d'un
gouverneur général même plus ce qui est
important dans la tournée de base direct
c'est que il a laissé entendre d'une
manière ou d'une autre enfin on n'a pas
d'enregistrement évidemment précis des
discours qu'il a pu faire dans toutes
les dans toutes les grandes villes
d'Afrique de l'Ouest mais il a laissé
entendre que les africains pourraient
accéder à la citoyenneté pleine et
entière à la citoyenneté française au
même titre que les Français de la
métropole puisque les Africains sont
sujets n'est-ce pas de l'Empire ils sont
ils sont régis par le Code de l'indigène
ils n'ont pas l'égalité avec les
citoyenneté française avec la citoyen
les citoyens français pardon et donc
Blaise Diagne a laissé entendre que la
citoyenneté pleine et entière serait
accordée aux Africains en échange de
leur participation à la guerre du droit
[Musique]
parcourt l'Afrique occidentale comme un
véritable si j'ose dire entre guillemets
juanègre un prince et en même temps un
prince de la République le programme de
Blaise Diagne est un programme très sage
si on peut dire enfin vu avec un regard
d'aujourd'hui peut-être aussi tout de
même mais même avec même avec le regard
de l'époque c'est un programme très
assimilationniste c'est à dire qu'il
fait sien le discours de la colonisation
le discours officiel le discours
humaniste le discours universaliste qui
puisent en partie dans les idéaux de la
Révolution française avec beaucoup
d'hypocrisie n'est-ce pas mais tout de
même ce discours qui veut faire des
Africains et de tous les coloniser des
Français comme les autres des Français
de couleurs différentes mais si on veut
mais des Français à part entière et qui
donc comptent sur l'école française pour
inculquer les valeurs de la France
républicaine et bien c'est un discours
très assimilationniste donc que Blaise
Blaise Diagne a mis en avant et auquel
il croyait sans doute très très
fortement
au mois de
avril mai 1918 les Allemands étaient
tout près de gagner la guerre ils
étaient tout près de Paris et puis
brusquement
ils infléchissent comme en 14 et il
s'est trouvé que la bataille est
déplacée sur Reims et Reims est au cœur
de la grande bataille de 18 avant la
contrefensive qui a lieu sur
Villers-Cotterêts et la grande
contre-offensive qui mènera la victoire
[Musique]
de nouveau recrutements pour une guerre
qui semble ne jamais finir la Champagne
se trouve aux prises avec une seconde
bataille de la Marne dans la nuit du 27
mai 1918 les Allemands déclenchent une
offensive contre la ville de Reims face
à l'ennemi le premier corps d'armée
coloniale renforcé par des bataillons
sénégalaises et algériens participent à
la défense du fort de la Pompelle
le fort et la dernière limite des lignes
françaises on le voit très bien sur
cette carte nous avons le fort de la
Pompelle ici tout ce qui est en rouge
donc c'est ce sont les troupes
françaises qui sont ici et tout ce qui
est en bleu à partir vraiment des
limites du fort ce sont les troupes
allemandes
alors il reprend l'importance tout
simplement parce qu'il se trouve sur un
compartiment de terrain relativement
élevé qui va intéresser l'allemand
puisque ça lui fait un poste
d'observation d'artillerie entre autres
très important voilà pourquoi d'un coup
il nous faut le reprendre et ils vont se
battre ensuite 4 ans pour le récupérer
les fossés vont être utilisés par les
soldats qui vont y creuser des SAPS des
souterrains en fait une sorte de cave
sous les structures qui vont permettre
de regrouper sur le site même l'effectif
de 1500 à 2000 soldats
[Musique]
les troupes coloniales résistent avec
acharnement mais font retraite vers les
faubourg de Reims où elle s'enterre dans
les tranchées à la mi-juillet le 32e
bataillon de tirailleurs sénégalais
parvient à enfoncer les lignes ennemies
et Sénégalais sont de la Montagne de
Reims et les pertes ils ont une conduite
absolument héroïque mais vraiment
héroïque il est perte sont énormes il
m'est arrivé de voir dans le journal de
marche que ça s'interrompre complètement
parce que un bataillon a entièrement
disparu entièrement entièrement
[Musique]
plutôt que le combat à l'arme blanche ce
qui est le plus craint tout au long de
la guerre c'est l'écrasement par par
l'artillerie l'écrasement des hommes par
l'artillerie et ces hommes ont dû subir
des bombardements effroyables dans leur
position et tenir la Montagne de Reims
ce qui a permis de sauver un
[Musique]
la défense de Reims est enfin assurée la
presse annonce la victoire tandis que la
propagande de l'ennemi se déchaîne
contre ses [__] que l'on sacrifie
ajoutant la défense de Reims ne coûte
aucune goutte de sang français
[Musique]
en guise de reconnaissance envers les
troupes coloniales la ville fait édifiée
un monument le monument aux noirs dont
une réplique existe encore aujourd'hui à
Bamako au Mali
le monument est inauguré le 14 juillet
1924 en présence d'Edouard Daladier
ministre des colonies et la presse de
l'époque célèbre avec en phase ses
statues d'ébène et de bronze ces corps
souples et puissants loyaux et un
comptable qui ont écrit avec leur beau
sang rouge des pages de gloire
inestimables face à cette montagne de
Reims un violet
le monument sera détruit par les
Allemands en 1940 une nouvelle stèle le
remplace inaugurée en 1963 en présence
du général Massu on la préférera selon
les termes officielles décoratives et
plus discrète que la précédente
pendant que la capitale faite
l'armistice le moment est venu de
dénombrer les pertes il y a eu à peu
près un soldat sur 5 30
000 soldats qui sont pas rentrés
c'est un chiffre effrayant cette
proportion de 22% à peu près d'abord il
indigne bien sûr au premier abord il
semble confirmer l'idée que les
Africains n'ont été que de la chair à
canon
encore une fois je ne juge pas le point
de vue moral bien entendu je suis de
ceux que qui estime que on n'avait pas
on n'avait pas envoyé ces gens combattre
pour une cause qui les concerné
absolument pas bon si on laisse ça à
part 22% c'est à peu près le même
chiffre le même pourcentage que leur
compagnon leur malheureux compagnons
fantassins français mais j'ajoute autre
chose que presque la moitié de ces
hommes sont morts de maladies de ces
Africains sont morts de maladies
beaucoup de Français sont également
morts de maladies pulmonaires mais les
Africains plus que les autres parce que
faut imaginer que ces jeunes gens sont
arrivés sans aucune préparation physique
ou choc climatique et aux maladies
européennes en particulier la
tuberculose et que même ils ont ramené
la tuberculose en Afrique
[Musique]
11 novembre 1918 c'est la défaite de
l'Allemagne et la France décide
d'occuper la Rhénanie une occupation
prévue pour 15 ans à titre de gage
d'exécution et traité de Versailles la
France envoie donc des troubles
d'occupation en Rhénanie peu près 95000
hommes et sur ces 95000 hommes 20 000
soldats coloniaux principalement des
noms africains pour 15000 et puis des
Sénégalais et des Malgaches imaginez non
seulement leur sort est injuste et en
plus on les fait occupé par des [__]
par des Schwartz des noirs et là c'est
l'humiliation totale et les courants je
dirais extrémistes allemands tous ceux
qui qui rejettent la présence française
tous ceux qui n'estiment que qui
estiment que l'Allemagne doit se servir
de cette défaite pour rebondir tous les
courants d'extrême droite dans lequel
les nazis sont enfin les nationaux les
futurs nationaux socialistes en train de
puiser leurs forces évidemment vont se
servir de cette présence noire d'une
façon extraordinaire
à travers une campagne qui l'ont
intitulé La Honte noire la honte noire
tigeoire ce chemin vous nichoirs se
chande désigne la campagne de haine
raciale que les nationalistes allemands
ont lancé contre les troupes coloniales
françaises il s'agit d'une campagne qui
repose principalement sur l'idée de la
bestialité sexuelle des coloniaux
c'est-à-dire que les soldats coloniaux
principalement accusés sont les
Sénégalais les Noirs mais également les
Nord-Africains qui sont aussi considérés
comme des troubles de couleurs comme des
Noirs par les Allemands ces troupes
coloniales sont donc accusés de crimes
sexuels particulièrement atroce de viol
de bestialités sexuelles sur des enfants
des vieillards et compris des jeunes
hommes il se tapissent dans les forêts
attendant
attendant le soir et surgissent tel des
bêtes fauves puis même suce le sang si
on accroît si on en croit certains
journaux s'il se sent de leur victime
donc c'est une campagne très dure très
violente avec des termes très très très
violent comme Yann noir pour désigner
ses soldats chien noir homme singe donc
une campagne qui
déni toute humanité à ses soldats
coloniaux qui occupent la Rhénanie à
partir de 1919 cette propagande
s'adresse aux Anglais ou x neutres comme
les Hollandais aux Suisses et aux
Américains surtout aux Américains de
façon elle est persuadée que la France
est en train de livrer l'Allemagne à
un espèce de d'abat tardissement de son
[__] derrière ce racisme très fort très
virulent qui existe en Allemagne envers
les troupe colonial il y a une idée
politique c'est nuire à la diplomatie
française et c'est de dire que c'est ce
sont les Français qui sont les vrais
coupables et ce sont les Allemands qui
sont les victimes ce sont les Français
qui sont les coupables et des Français
qui
veulent humilier les Allemands
la France est une nation haineuse
revancharde qui veut prendre sa revanche
en utilisant les femmes en condamnant et
et en châtiant les Allemands par leur
femme et en essayant de métisser la
rassalle en essayant de lui insuffler un
certain nombre de maladies comme le
choléra la peste ou encore certaines
maladies plus exotiques comme la lèpre
ou la maladie du sommeil que sont censé
porter les soldats coloniaux en plus de
la syphilis bien sûr car on lit dans la
presse nationalisme de l'époque que tous
les noirs sont civilisés et puis après
tout c'est bien normal disent des
nationalistes allemands que les porteurs
de civilisation française soient aussi
les porteurs de civilisation
face à une intense campagne aussi bien
menée aussi bien en Allemagne que qu'au
niveau international aux États-Unis ou
en Angleterre la France avait deux choix
retirer cette roue coloniale pour que la
campagne s'appelle pour qu'on entend
plus parler ou bien affirmer hautement
que tous les hommes sont égaux que
l'universalité
est la règle en ce qui concerne le genre
humain et défendre ses troupes
coloniales et nier absolument toutes les
allégations qui sont imputées autre
colonial en fait la France va faire l'un
et l'autre elle va considérer que cette
campagne nationaliste est un mensonge
mais en même temps elle va retirer peu à
peu presque honteusement cette colonial
d'abord les Sénégalais des juin 1920
puis les Malgaches en octobre novembre
1921 enfin les Antillais car il restait
encore 200 noirs dans l'armée française
des antillais qui étaient des citoyens
français on les retire en janvier 1923
et
à partir de 1924-1925 ce sont les
tirailleurs nord-africains marocains
algériens tunisien qui était considéré
comme des Noirs par les Allemands qui
sont attirer dans un contexte qui est à
l'apaisement évidemment à la fin de la
guerre on va pas mettre en avant le rôle
joué par les tirailleurs parce qu'on
sait que finalement il a été mineur en
revanche ce qu'on va mettre en avant à
travers la figure du héros noir c'est
c'est ce peuple ce peuple de la plus
grande France et donc ce qu'on mette en
avant 1918 c'est le fait que la nation
ça ne met pas cette figure tutélaire un
statut qui est à la République ou même
place de la Nation cette espèce de
d'énormes femmes avec des seins opulants
et à ses pieds et sont les monuments
qu'on retrouve de Hanoï à Dakar à
l'époque à ses pieds tous ses enfants
tend vers elle les bras pour en recevoir
les bienfaits c'est surtout comme ça
qu'il est emblématisé le héros
sénégalais il doit finalement remercier
la France d'avoir participé à la guerre
parce que grâce à la guerre il a aussi
prouvé
qu'il pouvait qu'il pouvait apporter
quelque chose et surtout de gagner les
mêmes droits d'ailleurs ce sera le
discours de Blaise Diagne en versant le
même sang vous gagnerez les mêmes droits
il faut être bien des trucages de la
propagande le héros c'est surtout un
héros qui grandit la France à travers
lui-même on ne manqua pas de distribuer
des promotions à certains de ces héros
quelques-uns d'entre eux seront nommés
sous-officiers ou officiers il l'était à
titre temporaire une fois la guerre
terminée bon il perdait leur titre fin
des mois les avantages liés au titre de
lieutenant à titre temporaire et puis
lieutenant à titre indigène et là c'est
tout le problème de la promotion dans la
dans l'armée française or j'ai compté le
nombre de d'officiers sortis de la
Première Guerre mondiale et qui sont
devenus officiers pendant l'entre de
guerre on en compte pas plus de 35 40
c'est-à-dire très peu de choses il y a
la promotion d'officier
noire originaire donc d'Afrique noire ne
s'est faite que largement après la
Seconde Guerre mondiale ce qui était
devenu officier pendant la Première
Guerre mondiale était l'été par leur
valeur et mettez souvent à presque
illettré presque un alphabète donc quand
il s'agit de rester officier dans
l'entre-deux-guerres et ben ils ont ils
ont bloqué au plus au mieux lieutenant
au mieux au mieux mais très souvent leur
carrière s'est arrêté assez
dramatiquement pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux comme un des fils de de sa
mojitore qui s'est suicidé
Charles Mangin est partisan de la force
noire de la création d'une armée noire
était partisan avant la guerre
les coloniaux et les colons pardon et
l'état-major étaient assez prudents sur
cette question et la guerre avait
tranché le débat mais le débat ressurgit
en 1918 avec la victoire est-ce qu'on
peut se passer finalement du d'une armée
noire ou est-ce qu'on doit la reconduire
et pour la reconduire pour essayer de
prendre un peu d'avance dans ce débat
Charles Mangin a exigé que l'on envoie
des Noirs en Allemagne et de son côté
Blaise Diane qui est député du Sénégal
milite lui pour l'égalité politique pour
l'extension de la citoyenneté française
à tout les les coloniaux et voit dans la
conscription et dans l'armée noire en
particulier le cheval de Troie des
droits politiques ce serait une façon la
conscription ce serait une façon
finalement d'étendre la citoyenneté
française on peut pas demander à un
Sénégalais à tirailleurs sénégalais
d'être un soldat de l'armée française de
verser son sang pour la patrie française
et en même temps lui dénier le droit
d'être un citoyen français et de voter
lorsque arrive l'armistice et puis qu'il
n'est plus question de citoyenneté
vraiment c'est quelque chose qui est
tout à fait enterré
il va y avoir une radicalisation
progressive de des mots d'ordre de des
militants politiques africains sous
l'effet de cet amertume donc il y a eu
un gratitude je pense une certaine
ingratitude et
il y a eu également
difficulté de la métropole ça c'est
certain alors les élites ont été déçus
et il s'est formé une nouvelle
génération de gens qui se sont dit ça
peut pas continuer comme ça et puis ce
que on peut reprocher aux Français c'est
non seulement la gratitude mais c'est le
mépris au début des années 20 personne
n'est pour l'indépendance c'est un mot
d'ordre qui va ensuite se faire jour en
particulier
dans les chez les militants communistes
et dans les marges du mouvement
communiste de des Africains qui sont
proches du mouvement communiste
mais qui est venu progressivement à la
suite de cette désillusion première
c'est ce que les africains vont appeler
la dette de sang la dette de sang
contractée par la France renverse ses
enfants africains morts pour la patrie
commune la majeure partie des soldats
coloniaux sont renvoyés en Afrique peu
sont démobilisés sur place un homme se
détache de l'anonymat et marque cette
période difficile de l'après-guerre la
mine s'engor
il est donc typique de ces tirailleurs
qui vont
à la suite de la grande désillusion des
promesses non tenus se radicalisés et
passer d'un apolitisme en 1920 à une
radicalité indépendante dès les années
22 23 on voit que le nom respect de
cette du sens a radicalisé les mythes
des militants qui se serait contentés
entre guillemets d'une citoyenneté
pleinée entière en 1920 alors que
personne ne réclamait l'indépendance
[Musique]
on dit que dans ce monde où plus rien
n'est à sa place la meilleure chance de
survie de ces hommes a été la fraternité
l'entraide la fidélité
mais derrière cette familiarité
apparente poilue et soldat coloniaux se
sont-ils vraiment rencontrés
[Musique]
on peut considérer qu'il y a eu
rencontre entre deux mondes pendant la
Première Guerre mondiale
les coloniaux en 1914 quand ils ont été
utilisés sur le terrain français sur le
terrain européen ils ont rencontré des
Français qui n'étaient pas du tout les
Français qu'il côtoyaient dans les
colonies qui étaient beaucoup plus dur
avec eux qui qui manifestait beaucoup de
racistes une autorité paternelle dans le
meilleur des cas raciste dans dans
le cas les plus courants et en France
ils ont connu une certaine fraternité
avec les poilus qui étaient leurs frères
d'armes au fond donc les gens sont
côtoyés ils se rendent compte pas
vraiment je pense alors il y en a
peut-être une mais moi j'ai pas été
témoin même
par personne d'interposée par document
interposés avec des rencontres de ou des
gens se parlent vraiment ils se
regardent ils peuvent sourire ils
peuvent applaudir voyez ça bon ils
peuvent même saluer ou mais de
rencontres individuelles entre une
personne qui va reconnaître l'autre dans
une culture moi j'ai pas vu ça au point
de vue individuel ce plan individuel
j'ai pas vu ça le problème c'est que moi
j'ai pas de matériaux des tirs de
tirailleurs venant de tirailleurs
sénégalais ou algérien ils n'ont pas
écrit leur carnet de route je n'en ai
pas où j'ai pas leur correspondante
écrite alors maman et je pense pas
qu'ils en envoyaient puis que les
voyaient pas pendant 4 ans et je peux
pas dire ce qui un Nice qui ressentait
mais je qui pensais ni comment il voyait
cette dernière je peux voir comment il
se conduisent comment ils vivent par on
va dire c'est ces gens qui vont se
soucis documentaire c'est pas ces
combattants qui prennent des photos ou
ses combattants qui font des croquis ou
ceux qui décrivent à leurs parents ce
qu'ils voient parce que c'était très
exotique
l'exotisme est souvent la très
principale cependant il a existé parmi
ces artistes combattants une volonté de
saisir l'Africain dans son authenticité
une expression un regard qui fait de ses
frères d'armes les sujets d'une histoire
commune
on les imagine alors à leur place parmi
leurs pères au sein d'une armée
réellement émancipatrice
c'est vrai que l'armée va être pendant
très longtemps il va s'afficher et va
même s'affirmer comme un creuset
fraternel et républicain
cette photographie s'inscrit bien dans
cette vision républicaine tu es mon
copain en même temps elle porte je
dirais ce qui est un peu la spécificité
française qui est le paternalisme elle
marque aussi le fossé je veux dire ce
blanc qui allume cette cigarette c'est
aussi regarder le tirailleur fume aussi
et puis devant il y a un vélo peut-être
qu'un jour il râpera sur la bicyclette
donc je trouve que évidemment
formidablement intéressant parce qu'on y
trouve toutes les ambiguïtés de ce
discours colonial républicain maintenant
est-ce qu'ils se sont rencontrés non pas
vraiment parce que ils reviennent pour
la plupart et quand ils se sont
rencontrés pendant la guerre c'était
souvent ambigu il y a eu il y a eu deux
sortes de rencontres elle a eu les
rencontres
je parle pas des rencontres au front il
y a une fraternité réelle réelle mais
disons à l'arrière c'est ça qui compte
il y a eu il rencontre avec les femmes
[Musique]
il y a eu des vrais des vrais liens
enfin je pense des vrais relations
c'était avec les infirmières les dames
de la Croix-Rouge etc ils se reposer à
l'arrière et l'air de beaucoup aimer les
dames en plus et là il y a eu pas mal de
relations qui ont été je vois ce que des
relations sexuelles enfin j'étais pas
très bien vu sans doute par l'état-major
et à l'arrière
on sait qu'il a pu se passer des choses
aussi de ce genre puisque il y avait des
blagues qui circulaient sur le front ou
les soldats ils ont entre eux quand tu
vas rentrer tu auras peut-être un enfant
qui a fait crème donc il y avait un
fantasme
du guerrier noir
très très sexuel et qui allait prendre
leur femme et leur faire des enfants au
café ou lait et puis il y a les marines
de guerre alors ça c'est très important
parce que l'image positive que se font
les Africains de la métropole c'est pas
l'intermédiaire d'une part de la
découverte de de des villes la
découverte d'une certaine fraternité au
front et les marines de guerre c'est la
chose qui retiendront par la suite d'une
espèce de le côté maternel oui il faut
bien maternelle de de ces marines de
guerre qui les soutiennent comme
infirmière comme il y a eu des unions
[Musique]
mon père a fait tout donc toute cette
guerre
en entier et puis après il est resté en
France
il avait décidé d'ailleurs que une
retournerait pas en Afrique et en même
temps que la France devait lui plaire
faut croire et puis après il y a eu ma
mère dont il est tombé amoureux ce qui
l'a fait restait en France
c'était une rencontre merveilleuse aussi
bien pour ma mère que pour mon père
si quelqu'un qui
qui
qui a combattu donc pour
un pays qu'il a toujours considéré comme
le sien en l'occurrence la France et je
peux dire qu'à cette époque
puis même à mon époque aussi à moi à
part de tomber sur quelques imbéciles ça
te descendre rien y faire
il n'a pas eu à trop à la retraité donc
une fierté oui moi j'en ai une sûreté
une certaine fierté que mon père soit
venu donc et que tout compte fait
peut-être aussi c'était peut-être
absurde quoi mais c'était autour de des
Français de le remercier
[Musique]